standing here before all of you i
honestly thought
i would be addressing you following a
very different verdict
i had planned to talk of the beautiful
future andrew and i had
before us i expected my webinar very
different
and in all honesty i am for the second
time
in a space of one year utterly shocked
and
fault the decisions made in these courts
by strangers
will never change the outcome that had
already come to us
for many many agonizing months we have
hoped
that justice would come in some way for
andrew
we have put our faith in the justice
system and all who work within it
we have waited with dated breath and
heavy hearts
as the dedicated prosecution barristers
investigation team
and thames valley police officers have
worked tirelessly
and whom we thank sincerely for all that
they have done
as they stood in our corner and fought
to ensure that these men were made to
repent
for their barbaric crimes
no verdict or sentence will ever bring
my incredible selfless and heroic
husband back
the results from this trial had i had
hoped would bring justice
but in reality make no difference to the
heart-wrenching pain
i will continue to feel for the rest of
my life
andrew was taken from us on that
horrendous night last year
his life was stolen and the lives of his
family and friends
altered forever
this crime whatever the outcome
deliberated over
in court was brutal and senseless
the way in which andrew was robbed of
his life we all know to be barbaric
and inexplicable i'm immensely
disappointed with the verdict given
today
andrew served in thames valley police
with honor
he went out night after night risking
his life for the safety and well-being
of the innocent
as all police officers do with passion
ultimately he laid down his life
for us all and it pains me more than i
can ever explain that this has not been
appreciated by the very people who
should have seen
his heroic and selfless duty
as so many other members of the public
total strangers clearly do
myself and andrew's family will never
come to terms with our new lives
we will never understand how such a
beautiful loving
decent human being could be dealt this
fake
[Music]
i now have my own life sentence to bear
and believe me when i say
it will be a much more painful
soul-destroying and treacherous journey
than anyone facing a meager number of
years in prison will experience
myself and our families will spend the
rest of our days missing him
loving him and being utterly proud of
the incredible man
that he was we will never forget the
kindness we as a family have received
from all who have supported us over the
past year
friends family total strangers and the
almighty unity of the thin blue line
from the depths of our hearts thank you